oh hey everybody welcome welcome welcome
into another exciting edition of Market
takes we are looking ahead to all the
big data releases coming out this week
and we have a lot uh I'm Dion rabone
reporter at the Wall Street Journal
thank you so much for joining us here on
Market takes listen a lot of stuff going
on this week we've got a number of
housing reports we got the August new
home sales report we have the case
Schiller home price index and the
pending home sales report I'm going to
tell you what all those are why they
matter what you need to look for in each
of those we have two big consumer
confidence indexes coming in this week
one from the conference board one from
the University of Michigan that's the
consumer sentiment report we get both
this week I'll tell you what those are
all about why they'll matter this week
those are going to be big I think and we
also get some big economic indicators we
get a revision for the GDP report that
one I think is undercover low-key going
to be a big one also get the pce report
and the advanced economic indicators
report from the Census Bureau so you're
going to want to watch out for all three
of those we will talk through why each
of those is important what the Met why
they matter what to look for let's start
it out with the real estate market and
what we're looking for in terms of
housing so first report that we've got
coming up is the new home sales report
for August that's out on Tuesday let's
throw up here on your screen just a
chart going back of what we're looking
at in terms of new home sales now I
wanted to go back 10 years to give
people a better idea of the environment
that we're in right now we've seen new
home sales picking up pretty
consistently since the start of the year
since late last year and then rising up
getting that big peak you saw there a
couple months ago then moving down but
moving back up
we have consistently been moving higher
in terms of the number of new homes sold
historically we are at a very high level
of new home sales we are down from those
2021 2022 levels which were very high
historic levels over a million new homes
sold in a month
but we are still very high approaching
800 000 homes we're expected to get down
a little bit from that this upcoming
reading for uh the next reading that we
have we're expecting sales to decline by
2.2 percent see about 698 000 new homes
sold listen the big picture here of what
we're looking at is you see we are
historically high and this chart just
really illustrating the way that new
home sales have picked up over the long
term over the long term over the past 10
years cooled down a little bit since
those big Peaks after 2020 uh when the
when the pandemic hit and everybody
wanted to go out and get a new house but
we are still going high we are at a high
level well that's important because we
have seen homebuilder sentiment decline
recently for the first time in several
months and we saw construction levels
dip to a three-year low so this is the
first time we've really seen that dip in
homebuilder sentiment means home
builders aren't good we've seen a big
pullback in terms of Home Builders
stocks and we have seen a decline in
terms of that real bullishness that we
saw in the Home Building economy why
does that matter big picture matters for
inflation also matters for the price of
housing which of course pushes up the
highest inflation when we've seen a big
glut of Supply right no one with an
existing home really is selling right
now we're seeing very few existing home
sales and those houses that were already
built being on the market people who
have low interest rates they locked in
at two or three percent they don't want
to come out here and sell their house
and have to buy a new one at seven seven
and a half percent mortgage rates so we
have seen that Supply decrease we've
seen new home sales in terms of new
homes being built pushing up and that's
pushed those home builder stocks up
we've seen that really rise in a big way
and that's kind of kept a lid on home
prices well if those new homes aren't
being built you could see that demand
has been consistent if the supply
declines prices could pick back up
you're going to want to keep an eye on
that we've seen homebuilders stocks
which had been booming all year really
pull back and an index an ETF of home
builder stocks put together by BlackRock
saw its biggest outflows since April of
2022 last month housing starts also down
11 0.3 percent last month we have just
seen a real big move in terms of toward
the negative side on the home building
front which had been a big bullish
Tailwind for the economy uh one thing
let's let's throw up another chart right
here let's talk about the markets I want
to put up here on your screen what we
are seeing in markets the big piece
there is it's all about bonds you see
the 30-year Bond that's that 30-year
Tino
Rising that's up by with prices down by
almost two full percentage points or two
full points uh that is a huge increase
in yields we're seeing the 30-year rise
well above the seven year the five year
it had been below those for a long time
so we are seeing big moves in the bomb
market and the 10-year note which is the
most traded which has some direct
correlation with those mortgage rates
we're seeing that rise in a big way well
over four and a half percent and just to
give you an idea of where we are let's
take a look at the one-year chart you
see there rising up in a big way even
when we go out three years you were just
seeing us up here near the peak same
thing long dated bonds are rising in a
major way the yields are rising in a
major way that makes everything more
expensive those mortgage rates probably
not coming down anytime soon and in fact
probably getting much higher and again
what we're seeing here just illustrating
the overall themes in the market in
terms of what we're seeing from the
bonds uh case Schiller home price index
is also coming out for July it's going
to give us some in-depth pricing numbers
likely higher likely moved up Prices
rose in June but that's continuing a
theme we will see also the pending home
sales index that's going to give us some
important Clues on whether home buying
is starting to heat up again which would
be unusual given that we are moving into
the fall and away from the summer
usually that's when home prices slow
down that's when buying slows down if we
do see a continued pickup that's
definitely something to keep your eye on
again those home prices have been a
cooling effect on inflation over the
past couple months that was expected to
continue through year end if home prices
start to rise back up because we're
seeing sustained demand decreasing
Supply well you could see home prices
start to push up inflation again keep
your eye on that let's talk real quickly
about consumer confidence I want to put
a chart up here on your screen of the
conference boards U.S consumer
confidence index again
going back 10 years you see we are
higher than we have been historically
getting down from some of those levels
we saw in 2019 and in 2021 but still
very high but we are seeing those
numbers start to decline we saw last
month a home builder or sorry consumer
confidence decrease to 106. it's
expected to decline again this month uh
last month confidence fell and the
previous month was revised lower so what
you're seeing there is just that
starting to move lower in terms of
consumer confidence Dana Peterson Chief
Economist at the conference board said
quote August disappointing headline
number reflected dips in both the
current condition and expectations index
as in people saying right now I don't
feel good and I don't feel good about
the future Dana says write-in responses
showed that consumers were once again
preoccupied with Rising prices in
general and for groceries and gasoline
in particular and listen when you're
looking up there on your screen this
chart just illustrating the way that
consumer confidence has risen recently
it's been strong but it could be moving
back down lower as we know those gas
prices are rising we know those food
prices are rising we've seen that we
also get the University of Michigan's
consumer sentiment index that's out on
Friday that also declined last month but
it is about 15 and a half percent higher
than a year ago University of Michigan
saying it's about 35 percent above the
all-time low because remember in 2022 we
got to those all-time lows on the
University of Michigan's consumer
sentiment index we're well above that
but we are well below the historical
average reading of 86 so last month it
was 67.7 way below the average reading
of 86. we'll see if that holds up and
we'll see how consumers feel about their
lives the conference Awards index more
about how consumers feel about business
the business environment University of
Michigan is more about how do you feel
about your own life and what's going on
last but not least let's talk about
economic indicators we are going to get
the advanced economic indicators report
from the Census Bureau that is out on
Friday it is a monthly survey that gives
us Advanced statistics on U.S
international trading Goods domestic
retail inventories and domestic
wholesale inventories basically how much
are people buying and are they being
able to sell it we know inventories were
a big part of the GDP picture in 2022
that's come off and GDP is still
expected to rise so keep your eye on
that bets on GDP growth are really a big
part of that Bond story when I showed
you those yields just shooting up that's
really about expectations for the U.S
economy continue growing for inflation
to potentially pick back up and for the
long term right you see the 10 and 30
year those 10 and 30 are months those
yields are really Rising taking off
that's all about this GDP growth Story
the Atlanta feds GDP now poll still
shows U.S GDP expected to grow five
percent in the third quarter that is
huge
um so this Advanced economic indicators
report on Friday is going to give us a
big look at that we will also get
another revision the third revision for
U.S second quarter GDP that's out later
this week on Thursday uh it's the last
one that we'll get so that's expected to
show US GDP Rose 2.3 percent in the
second quarter higher than 2.1 percent
so basically we're seeing GDP rise and
expectations for it to continue Rising
through the end of the year this will be
a big week for the bond market and as we
have seen that's been influencing the
stock market in a big way we also get
pce the pce inflation report personal
consumption expenditures that is
released in the personal income and
outlays Report that's out on Friday
watch out for that that's the big
inflation report that the FED wants
that's their favorite gauge it's
expected to rise in terms of the overall
headline number but decline in terms of
the core stripping out food and energy I
know a lot of you are saying what does
it matter what inflation's doing if you
don't count food and energy those are my
biggest costs talk to the FED about that
they're talking about core and core is
expected line listen that's going to
wrap it up for us here on Market takes
I'm Dion rabone reporter at the Wall
Street Journal thanks so much for being
with us we hope you will come back and
be with us again next time